to Iran which of course has been shaken
by anti-regime protests for three months
now at least two people have been
executed in connection with the
demonstrations and activists are warning
that others face the same fate now
German politicians are doing their part
to raise awareness of the plight of some
of these political prisoners
a rapper belonging to Iran's Kurdish
minority famous not only for his music
but also his criticism of the Islamic
Republic
he was arrested by the regime's forces
in October while protesting and
sentenced to death for allegedly harming
National Security his family is afraid
he could soon be executed
This Is My Cry for Help For Justice for
God's sake help me I'm not articulate
and I'm not able to have my voice heard
who can speak out about my pain somebody
please help me
a cry for help that did not go unnoticed
here in Germany
Carlos Casper A Member of Parliament has
taken on political sponsorship of yazin
and is now amplifying his mother's calls
for his release
I've sent a letter to the Iranian
Ambassador here in Germany but I expect
Yasin to be released and not to be
executed because his execution could
happen any day now
and Casper's not the only one in the
past few days dozens of members of the
German Parliament have become sponsors
of political prisoners and their number
is growing iwan re was the first one
she's publicly speaking out to help save
too much Sali another well-known rapper
Who's reportedly being tortured in jail
without access to the lawyer he
requested re-shares updates about his
condition and is glad that so many
colleagues are now joining her
among them are experienced MPS and
inexperienced MPS conservative MPS and
Progressive MPS what unites us is that
we really want to give these people a
face there's the saying say their names
and that is exactly what we do with
those for whom we take responsibility
member of the German Parliament Norbert
rutkin is another sponsor taking on the
case of Mustafa nili a well-known human
rights lawyer who has now imprisoned
himself to raise attention for his case
and also to send a signal of support for
other people like him in Iran
they have a goal that they're not giving
up on freedom their freedom the freedom
of Iran and this is a historic moment a
possibility for Change and that's why
the Europeans should be alert and make
their small modest contribution to make
this revolution for freedom and
emancipation of the people successful
and while sanctions and other political
measures are being discussed rutkin and
his colleagues will keep making as much
noise as possible to make sure
Mustafa and all the others stay alive